[拍手]
勝志
これは屍は生きる子であるという意味です
私が学ぶ大阪大学医学部の解剖室にはこの言葉が掲げられています
私たち学生は解剖学実習や
40種を通して先人たちの c
から学び石になっていきます
人は必ず死にます人生は一度しかない
みなさんはいったい何のために生きますか
何に挑戦しますか
私の挑戦は南太平洋の小さな島から始まりました
私は2年間南太平洋に浮かぶパラオ共和国という国で生活習慣病の研究をしていました
日本とパラオ行き来しながら研究を行っていたのですが一人で海外で研究を行うのは
とても大変でした
そんな時助けてくれたのが現地の保健省の職員だったて3位でした
彼の応援のお陰で私は研究を続けることができました
しかしある時パラを訪れると彼が心筋梗塞で亡くなったと告げられました
彼はまだ40代でした
国の生活習慣病対策を行っていた彼がその生活習慣病で亡くなってしまった
私は恩人の死にしばらく涙が止まりませんでした
どうしたらよかったんだろう
以上資源が足りない中で命を救うには何が必要か
途上国でも疾病構造が変化し感染症から生活習慣病が
シーンの多くを占める時代になってきました
また途上国だけではなく日本でも医療支援が足りない地域はたくさんあります
高齢化するにつれてこれまでのようにどこに行っても同じレベルの医療を受けられる
時代が終わろうとしています
ほうとうする医療費を税金だけでまかなうことは難しくなっていくでしょう
地上中心の4医療の在り方では
なり行かなくなっていく
私は病気になったら直すという
地上中心の医療のあり方から病気にならないようにする
病気になったとしても早期発見早期対応する予防中心の医療のあり方への変化が鍵で
あると考えるようになりました
では
21世紀の予防医療のあり方をどうあるべきか
それを考えた時に医療の歴史を振り返りました
医療の歴史を振り返ってみるとこれまで予防医療には2つの段階があったことがわかり
ます
まず
70年ほど前まで主要な死因は幹線所でした
結核や肺炎によって多くの方が亡くなりました
この感染症中心の時代の予防
それは
隔離です
病院と社会を明確に分けて金が映らないようにする
この隔離方の予防医療を私は予防医療
1.0と呼びます
猛威を振るっていた感染症ですが抗生剤や抗結核薬の誕生により死亡者は1950年
ごろから激減していきます
次に問題となってきたのが
脳血管疾患でした
これは高血圧などの基礎疾患を背景として脳の血管が破れ
なくなってしまう
これは1950年代から80年代の
医療者の研究啓発活動によって減っていきます
この時代の予防医療は知識を中心とした
予防医療です
異常者が情報を発信し啓発活動を行いその知識に基づいて市民が県高校のを起こす方
いった知識を中心とした
トップダウン型の予防医療を私は予防医療2.0と呼びます
例えば喫煙タバコを吸っていると脳血管疾患につながります
だから禁煙しましょう
例えばしようかないものばかり食べていると高血圧になります
高血圧は脳血管疾患を引き起こしますだから使用を減らしましょう
このような知識を中心とした
予防医療の考え方のもと多くの生活習慣病対策が行われてきました
しかし今起こっているのはこの知識を中心とした
予防医療の限界です
例えば出演
タバコを吸うと健康に悪いことはもうみんなわかっています
これ以上医療者がた僕が悪いといっても禁煙は進めません
例えば心肺蘇生講習横で家族が倒れた時に新たたちが心肺蘇生講習を行う
心肺蘇生を行えば重症化を予防することができる
これは皆さんわかっているはずですしかし健康のことは医療者に任せておけばいいので
地域で行われる
心肺蘇生校
書にはいかない
このような
予防医療
実現していく上で阻んでいる要素というのが知識不足ではなく市民の主体性の問題で
あるということが分かりました
予防医療を進める医療者は知識中心主義から脱却する必要がある
そして市民が主体的にコミュニティで健康増進活動を起こす仕組みを設計しまた主体者
として地域の中でリーダーシップを発揮できる人材を生み出していく必要がある
ん
この市民主体の予防医療もともアップだための某医療を
私は予防医療3.0と呼びます
これはこれまでの知識を広めることを中心とした予防医療ではなく
市民が行動を起こすことを中心とした予防医療です
この予防色3.0実現のためのキーワードは2つあります
一つはテクノロジーの民主化
そしてもう一つが community リーダーシップです
テクノロジーの民主化とは病院や研究所で
中央集権的に管理されているテクノロジーの市民に開放し誰もが簡単に使えるような
状態にすることです
例えば
自動体外式除細動器 ad は2004年に初めて一般市民が使えるようになりました
これによって街で倒れた人を ad を用いて助けることができる救命率8
社会復帰率が劇的に改善しました
もう一つのキーワードがコミュニティリーダーシップです
まず医療者が勇気を持って
病院から地域に出ていく必要があるあっ
そして
地域で市民とともに
バッ
市民とともに
コミュニティを活性化していく必要がある
この
新たなコミュニティを
生み出し地域でリーダーシップを発揮していくことによってこれまで
知識中心の予防医療2.0では届かなかった
個人を変えることができるのです
予防医療3.0推し進める医療者を
市民を私はヘルスケアアントレプレナーと呼びます
21世紀のヘイルスキーアントレプレナーとなる存在
これはテクノロジーに親和性が高いスマホ世代の若者だと私は考えました
若者からヘルスケアの課題を解決していくそれによって
ヘルスケアアントレプレナーを生み出すこういった思いで私は命学生プロジェクト
立ち上げました
最初学生3人から始まったプロジェクトはこれまで世界6か国
54の学校の400名を超える中興大学生にプログラムを提供し
認知症心臓突然死に対する
80を超えるアイデアを生み出してきました現在スタッフは40名
13の企業に支えられプログラムを展開しています
私たちはまず大学生が医療課題を熟議しテーマを決定します
そして大学生が自ら地域の学校に行き参加者を募集しますそして選ばれた参加者
中興大学生約120人が4カ月の時間をかけて教育プログラムを
だ
薬や企業で
受けそしてそれぞれオリジナルの解決策を考えます
そしてその解決策をそれぞれの地域で実践し成果を発表します
生まれたプロジェクトは低減開発対話
研究の4つをゴールにし進んでいきます
私たちは
医療テクノロジーリーダーシップの重要性を何度も伝えます
そのプロジェクトは本当に良的価値があるのかそのプロジェクトは民主化された
テクノロジーを用いているかそのプロジェクトはコミュニティでリーダーシップを発揮
しているか何度も何度も
と言います
例えば2016年度私たちは心臓突然死を減らすにはと課題に取り組みました
彼女は和歌山から参加してくれた高校生の岡田さんです
家族が心筋梗塞になった経験から自分も心臓とつええし対策に何か貢献できないかと
参加してくれました
彼女は教育プログラムや地元の
消防署へのヒアリングを通して ad の使用率が3.7%と極めて低いことそして
その原因として通報から ad が遠くまでの時間がかかり過ぎていることを課題とし
て捉え
これをテクノロジーを用いて解決できないかと
メンターと白を
朝重ねました
そこで彼女は ad にタブレット端末をつけることによって
つけることを実現する adi というプロジェクト始めました
この adi というプロジェクトは119番通報で得られた位置情報をタブレット月
の ad に送信しそしてその近くにいる人がその通知に気づき ad を持ってきて
くれると言う
いうアイディアですこのアイディアによってこれまで取りにいかなくてはいけなかった
ad が向こうからやってくるということで時間を短縮することが可能になりました
彼女は地元の師匠猛将市役所スーパーに協力を依頼
三者の協力を得て実証実験を行いまたその過程で地元のスーパー全店に ad を導入
することを実現しました
彼女は現在も adi の開発に向けて取り組んで継続して取り組んでいます
彼女のような
テクノロジーを用いてヘルスケアの課題を解決しコミュニティでリーダーシップを発揮
していく
そういった人材が多くまれーそしてその活動により病気になる人が減っていくこれが
予防色3.0が実現した世の中です
予防医療3.0は21世紀の医療の道しるべになると考えています
テクノロジーの民主化
とコミュニティだーシップは私たちが医療を行う上で忘れてはいけない
岩科学であり神術であるという言葉を思い出させてくれているのかもしれません
過去に起きた事実は変えられない人は今を生きるしかないんです
しかし過去から学び
未来を
切り開いていけば過去の意味は多少なりとも変えられる
先人たちから学びよりよい未来を切り開いていけるのは若者しかいないと思います
若者の力で未来はきっとよくできる
私はパラオの恩人に
恥じない生き方をしていつか彼がなくならなくてもよかった
世の中を作りたいと思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]